yes we do have socialism in this country
socialism for the rich and I'll give you
an example the the the the first kind of
economic experiment that people learn in
this country is a lemonade stand for
little kids right let me show you why
this is deceptive and part of the reason
capitalism is failing you
the little kid is out there selling
Dollar Glasses of lemonade
you haven't bought the lemons kid your
mommy did just like the government buys
stuff for these big companies you didn't
buy the knife that you cut the lemons
with a matter of fact you probably
didn't even cut the lemons you don't own
the pitcher you don't own the house you
never paid the water bill you didn't
bring the table outside right and you're
not going to clean everything up when
it's over so you are the exemplifying
precise example of what the American
corporation does which is live off the
welfare of the state to make money for
itself and meanwhile you're fighting
imaginary communism when it's just
corporatism